at this point next year we'll be fresh
off the first season of the Alliance of
American football eighteen ten weeks
starting next February ninth and the man
who founded this league Charlie ever saw
right here and the Rich Eisen show look
at us here look at us talking 14 years
ago you and Suzy took me in off the
streets for my first Thanksgiving away
from home that's what we do that guy
over there he knows he knows that tree
but into several this is yeah this is
how you should be introduced to Los
Angeles it really is yeah so it's good
to see you sir you too minutes so
without that Thanksgiving this would
never have happened not a million years
that was it that was that that vegan
Turkey later became Giselle's
dress so all right let's sink our teeth
run into this right away charlie why why
this league why you don't know how long
my relationships are with the NFL I
think what always shocked me was
Superbowl ends and everything falls off
a cliff there's like 80 million fewer
people watch sports on the weekend
starting the weekend after the Super
Bowl for six months and one third of all
fantasy players stop playing all forms
of fantasy and if you take March Madness
out it's like 40 million people and so
if you did that in any other business if
I told you that you know uber could only
operate for six months a year in the
other six months a year there was just
nothing and I said hey I'm gonna launch
a new Ebor in that exact window you
would invest everybody would want to get
on board and so football had that and
then on the other side of it was you had
this massive group of players and
they're like twenty seven twenty eight
thousand Division one players every year
that become available and know where to
play because they're only 1200 news
spots in the NFL so we looked at that
and it was like okay there's obvious and
then the minute that I started talking
to Paul Ian and he said yeah I'm this is
something we should be doing I'm
interested in doing it changed that
changed everything cuz my dad said yeah
my dad said talk to Bill to see if
you're crazy and Bill goes you know I
would co-found this with you I called my
dad was like does that count as support
here's a guess all right all that counts
is support and obviously you know your
dad
Dick Ebersol one of the legends in the
television business sports entertainment
also behind the XFL and you were the
director of the 34:30 on that so you
obviously know what worked there and
what might not work here and that
obviously is about the players here yeah
you need to use your you know your uber
analogy if I'm used to driving one of
the luxury cars that ubers driving
around I might not get that app in the
offseason if I've got to drive a jalopy
so who are the players that you're
identifying one of the things that that
bill really opened my eyes to and a lot
of the other people that we brought in
so it's it's Bill Polian but then
running football ops is Jay K McKay and
Troy Polamalu and Jared Allen and Justin
Tuck and Hines Ward one of the things
that became really clear early on was
that getting great players is more
science than an art and so if you look
at we're gonna run our draft three or
four weeks after the NFL does its final
cut down so you have 900 players you
become available September 3rd this year
we're running our season from the week
after the Super Bowl to the NFL Draft
so for players there's nowhere else
there's nothing else to be doing in that
window and you want to show off your
wares because if you've been caught by
the NFL or whatever that's a great
opportunity and then the third thing is
you got to put great coaches on the
field something that hasn't really been
done certainly not since the USFL but in
the last 25 years and so as we've rolled
these coaches out we roll that Spurrier
coach Steve Spurrier the head Ball Coach
in Orlando Brad Childress with Michael
Vick as his offensive coordinator in
about 48 hours we're gonna announce our
head coach in Memphis and you're gonna
see that the pattern here is that these
guys either coached or played in Super
Bowls or they won national championships
we want to put the best talent on the
field off the sidelines so the guys
between the lines can actually perform
so Charlie Eversole the founder of the
Alliance of American football sake
co-founder is Bill technically a cocoa
vanilla co-founder co-founder it would
be insane if I launched a football
league without bilbo I don't want to get
you in probably no please don't
I've been on the business end of that
way back in the day fines etc don't want
to do that so we're for those who may
not know we're where these teams going
to go so
we've announced the first three cities
we've announced Orlando Atlanta and
Memphis and we'll announce the last five
cities over the next four weeks I think
okay um my dad told me that all good
stories should be dripped out very
slowly so we're rolling them out you
know one at a time did you did you
personally call Spurrier didn't Steve
called JK so JK McKay who is our head of
football operations with Troy Polamalu
played with Steve in Tampa and Steve
Steve was his quarterback and when we
announced he called and said I want a
coach for you or necessary now only now
it's when we were doing this several
months ago cuz we didn't I don't to this
day I don't know how Steve knew what we
were doing we call him said I really
want to do this and that was the of all
the coaches we have that was the most
like emphatic which was part of the
reason we announced Orlando first was he
cannot be contained
he cannot be contained we were we were
just joking when that that piece of news
came out charlie is that we've got to
our right a putting green from the
Callaway corner would you want one of
those on the sidelines to keep him
occupied during he'll think that we know
we got him a lot of extra visors okay
and they've got extra bounce in them so
when he gets play to play he can bounce
them off the ground and pick them back
up one motion as you know it's an
entertainment product that you're
putting out in the field it is to see
that sort of it is your and if if no
better example of it would be safe spa
of course so when it all comes down to
it how is the NFL received this news
from you to us the NFL's complimentary
like we we look at a relationship with
the league as we look at the MLS and the
Premier League soccer is that not only
should they coexist but they should be
able to support each other and help each
other and so one of the things about
obviously having bill at the top of this
but also the types of coaches we're
bringing in the advisors that we have
working with the league are about you
know really messaging to the NFL that a
we have zero interest in competing with
them that's a fundamental waste of time
mainly because we're in a different
season mm-hmm but second of all for all
of the ills or lack of ills around the
NFL ultimately you're talking about the
most
sports entertainment product in the
United States by a wide margin if you
took the next four closest sports and
you added them together you'd still have
only one-sixth of the rating of an
average NFL game and so we look at them
as somebody that is like I said
complementary then how do they view you
though it's look items that I mean you
know that you will you more than anybody
knows how positive relationship I've had
with the league for a really long time
right we're not in Atlanta by accident
like we didn't we're not gonna go in
charging into what is maybe the most
powerful owner in the league and say
like oh we're gonna set up in your
backyard without at the very least
knowing that were not let's say we're
not persona non grata so what would you
say to the average age of the players
are gonna because the average NFL career
remarkably is about four years long and
that's why I always think of whenever
I'm at a rookie symposium that I look
across that room of all the drafted
players 256 men big men on campus - from
their campuses half of them will have to
choose something else to do in their
career three and a half to four years on
average after they start playing it is
that the those the guys that you're
targeting I mean who are you guys
targeting so those first of all that
number is an average based on who
actually plays like who actually gets
out and plays on the field that's how
they measure that stat when you talk
about players that just make the roster
the number drops significantly so you're
talking about an average age it's
probably like 2021 that that are
starting in the NFL because of the three
year rule and by the time they get out
there are only 23 24 years old and one
of the things that we look at is we look
at football as a moment in your life not
your whole life and so a lot of what
we're building is a support structure so
every year you plan our league is a one
year scholarship to vocational and
secondary education for a career beyond
football career training similar to the
program that I launched with the White
House three years ago with first lady
Michelle Obama about training veterans
we're going to be using a lot of the
same programs with with players and then
last but not least by putting Troy at
the top of this Polamalu
one of those we want to focus on is
longevity Troy in one of by far the most
brutal positions in all of professional
sports was able to have a 12 or 13 year
career in the NFL entirely predicated
around how he took care of himself one
of things that you'll see over the next
couple
our training program our nutrition
program our health and wellness and our
medical program is unlike anything
that's ever existed in professional
sports I want to take a break here
Charlie can go and come back you know
one of the things about the XFL that
that there were some aspects of the XFL
that did leave him a positive mark on
the way that the NFL was presented for
sure we never saw anybody go with he
hate me on the back of new jersey but
there are way and and I heard an idea
that you and I talked about off air
after I read about it that I think the
NFL should adopt already and I wanted
that's that's a tease for the audience
and excellent tease and for the
television audience when when we come
back we're gonna stroll down memory lane
of my greatest reality show achievement
it's my only reality show achievement
but it was great man
it was it was great great I have a great
anecdote for you about a great escape I
love that show this is a great man for
me to be able to put on a bomber jacket
professionally I never had that
opportunity before or since which what
gives maybe you should wear one on the
show that's what Dionne told me that I
should get my hair done and I'm like I
don't want to get my hair done I've got
to go back on the show he goes it's your
show you could wear a hat for two weeks
that's good
nothing's gonna showed up at the Met
Gala last night we're by the way the
Mets we had a big game last that's again
it's not big not not the gallery Charlie
of us all here on the Rich Eisen show
more with Charlie when we come back with
PJ Carlesimo still to come the Alliance
of American football coming to a town
near you potentially next February ninth
2019 CBS right is your partner the
Tiffany Network CBS Super Bowl the
weekend before on CBS and we premiere
the following weekend on Saturday night
okay 8:00 p.m. on CBS have you
identified announcers yet have you have
you gone down there no what's your
availability I am free on February the
9th 2019 it's excellent let me just call
booth
excuse me I mean I don't know who you
are anymore see do I know your name how
quickly it happens that was real fast
I'm on me oh we got a 2009 to February
9th 2019 yeah yeah next PBS America's
most watched network from what I've
heard for quite some time now yeah it's
alright you say you're gonna announce a
coach in Memphis give me a hint
give me a hint we believe very deeply in
the Alliance of players and the game and
so we think that should be reflected in
the coaches okay
so somebody who is related to the
Tennessee area sure but I wouldn't focus
on that aspect so it's gonna okay who
else not Jeff Fischer well hold on I
didn't say anything about not being
Peyton Manning okay Payne didn't want to
do the Thursday night games because he
wanted to come coach ten weeks in I got
a good one I got a good one in this man
is a really good poker face he's really
good at this but I'm gonna throw it
Eddie George oh god that's a good name
come on a good name the offensive
coordinator Dwayne the rock Johnson I'll
be great right season three of ballers
or season for ballers is actually gonna
be them coaching the Memphis team that's
the twist people don't realize that he
doesn't want to own anymore he just
wants to you know his roommate at the
you was was Sapp yeah him and Sapp were
on the same defensive line together the
rock Warren Sapp had to it was crazy
there was also one former SNL former SNL
star was on that team as well on that
you team that team was and that team was
totally insane look it up on the Google
and then they go to Notre Dame and they
embarrass us on our own of course you
think I've talked there by the way you
know I'm glad that of course you
wouldn't Notre Dame right there and
you're a Notre Dame guy well I like and
Giants you know no you know that's there
you go you know Michigan a Notre Dame we
were new rivalry cuz Notre Dame decided
to play us again that thankfully yeah
thankfully well we know not what
happened was not having that win on the
calendar each year it was bad for our
schedule so we had to do it
speaking of fiction when was the last
time you saw Rudy hey by the way you
know what I love the Rudy story every
time you give me that it's false every
time you go to Michigan they go he
sucked I'm like yeah that was the point
of the movie the only difference is you
would have started at Michigan that's
more false stuff that's more false stuff
I mean we're all and I know I'm really
hidden in here too it's almost as fake
as the the shilling bloody sock that is
totally fake that is that is food dye
that is food dye number five he has a
scar on his ankle he had surgery twice
not it who hasn't but he didn't have it
because of that see that's why Charlie
ever Sol's League is gonna be very
successful II understand which works and
what is it you're still not over 3-0
it's all good I get it so the
elimination of kickoffs and onside kicks
and I got the elimination two kickoffs
but the elimination of onside kicks I
remember let me ask you a question yes
which would you rather see would you
rather see a hands team who you have not
seen the whole game decide the entire
fate of the game or watching let's just
say out of left field Tim Tebow on his
own 35 going forth in ten and if you get
if he converts they go for it so let me
just hide - mogi hold on right there
there's two things right there there's
two things right there so instead of an
onside kick it's one attempt at getting
a first down from ten yards away from
your own 35 on your own 35 you lose it
you give it up you give it up but if you
make it you get to keep the ball rack
that's instead of an onside kick that's
what I'm saying the NFL should adopt
because the NFL is you know is would
love to get rid of kickoffs I think for
the safety aspect statistically you have
the exact same chance of converting a
fourth in 15 as you do getting an onside
kick and so we what we looked at is
think about the number of games that get
decided by onside kicks and it's born I
mean it's not an interesting play it see
you're putting a ton of pressure on a
guy who hasn't been on the field
basically at all and then you're
basically running a suicide play I would
much rather see it on the quarterback
who it's been on and on the defense to
actually stand up and do it and then you
get another Drive like that's what
you're looking for is you're looking
for the two-minute sold I love that idea
and I think the NFL should you you know
pilot it for the NFL and and do it now
it'll be like the sky cam with the XF
that's what that was exactly right the
sky cam and also the the the Steadicam
that's right running into the huddle and
miking players the XFL did all of them
yeah and now we see that all the time
the NBC you know your dad's a Sunday
Night Football package had an entire
game on Thursday night shot from the sky
Canada sky camp yeah and now they have
the two sky cam so you high and low you
don't ya know I mean look here's the
thing about the broadcast the broadcast
was effectively unchanged for 70 years
you had three cameras you had it to 20
to 50 and the 20 right up in the rafters
and it would just follow and then they
put the sky cam over X I fell I said the
biggest mistake made it out of XFL was
that NBC and WWE didn't take an
ownership stake in sky cam because it
didn't exist basically right had been
run my dad had used it once in the 80s
over in Orange Bowl and other than that
had never been used
and then the next season sky cam was
over under every NFL game well before I
let you go I could not also help but
notice the quarterback you just plucked
out of thin air is the guy that you
prefer to see take that fourth down play
you mentioned you mentioned the Mets and
it just like immediately went to my head
Tebow is that would you would you want
him in the league we want the best
available player do you want Tim Tebow
and they want the best available player
on a sec is Tim not one of the best
available players and that that is
debatable but in terms of name
recognition I don't know there is no
better name you could associate Johnny
Manziel would you be interested in
having him yeah we want quality talent
at the end of the day here's the thing
right what blows my mind is that you
only have 18 gigs in the NFL 1,800
positions right that are getting filled
you got a lot of really good players
that are sitting on the sidelines not
getting reps so we want to see them and
look at the end of the day we expect our
players to to live up to their their you
know discipline and all the other stuff
but at the end of the day you want to
put the best most entertaining talent on
the field to play good football and you
know Spurrier said it best about Tebow
how great would it be to see to Florida
Heisman Trophy winners on the field at
the same time
I'm just saying at Charlie Eversole on
Twitter the Alliance of American
football as you matriculate this ball
down the field luck yeah and at the AAF
at VA AF okay very good
not not AAF at the a just like Ohio
State right there
why do we have to do that we share that
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience